let's go next to our caller from the 303
area code who's calling from 303 today
can you hear me all right David yeah
who's this this is Patrick calling from
Colorado
hey Patrick what's going on so I'm
wondering if you saw the Sean Hannity de
Blasio interview last week no how was it
Oh horrifying just just horrifying
in what sense though because comedy was
asking his weird questions and attack
questions or because de Blasio was
working oh yeah well I mean de Blasio
did okay I think his position not
something I'm fully onboard with but
just honestly just the way that like
Sean Hannity is definitely one of the
worst when it comes to being unable to
ask questions that are even grounded in
reality but I have to say though I'm
like I've mentioned this before and I
don't know if you've heard me say this
or others it's probably new to other
people who are watching this or
listening to this sean hannity is
absolutely deplorable and disgusting he
has a horrible history with his
real-estate investments of effectively
being like a slumlord type dude he his
politics are disgusting his attack
interviews are just vile personally he
is super nice every time I've seen him
in person at different radio events he's
way nicer than a lot of the left
left-wing beat of media people there are
left-wing media people that a lot of
people in my audience probably really
like in terms of their politics who are
disgustingly vile people who react to
you saying hi as if you are just like a
piece of dirty gum on the bottom of
their shoe Hannity is super nice and
he'll stick around and take pictures
with whoever and talk to whoever I have
to give him credit for that even though
his politics are disgusting oh yeah and
like not saying anything about the guy
person of course I'd like it really
serious like his inability to
oh yeah like the the thing that Kyle
kolinsky actually did cover it just the
other day but only a small segment about
taxes and the thing is like even to this
day Sean Hannity which says 70 cents out
of every dollar when he is talking about
the income tax and it's just insane to
me that you cannot get like the marginal
tax rate oh yeah a lot of people I would
say they don't understand it but with
Hannity I think you're suggesting he's
deliberately misleading and I think
that's probably the case yeah I have no
doubt that he is and like even in my
personal life I've had some people on
the right with blamed how income tax
works to these people on multiple
occasions yeah but something about just
like I don't know if it's just their
inability to comprehend a nuance or
something but inability and the
athenians of comprehending it I think
it's a combination of the two yeah and
of course that nuanced comprehension
goes into every single issue you can
possibly bring up absolutely Patrick
thank you appreciate the call check out
that interview will do all right take
care thank you